[Music]
faint hope this Wednesday night the vast
search Zone in the North Atlantic where
noises detected from the missing
submersible the Canadian P3 detected
underwater noises questions about
whether the vessel could handle such
deep Dives and he was trapped in a sub
for four days keep on praying and don't
exercise the man who survived history's
deepest undersea rescue and got out with
just 12 minutes of oxygen left the
investigation into a deadly Chopper
crash that killed two Canadian Air Force
crew members by celebrating tradition
and history on this National indigenous
people's day we are a generation that is
actually moving forward
foreign
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
those who are searching for the missing
submersible in the North Atlantic say
they have to have hope but time is
running out for the five people on board
including a father and son and the
founder of the company that built the
vehicle the area of ocean Searchers are
covering is vast it reaches depths of
almost four kilometers a Canadian
military surveillance aircraft did
detect some noises underneath the waves
yesterday and again today the search
area has now been expanded this Canadian
Maritime Patrol aircraft is scanning the
ocean plus more rescue vessels have
arrived they cannot waste a minute if
it's still intact it's believed only
about a day's worth of oxygen is left
for those on board and the U.S Coast
Guard says they have no idea where it is
whether it's operable or whether it's
sitting on the ocean floor whether it's
in the sea column whether it's in the
surface I you know I it's all
speculation and and we're just we're
just not in the business of speculation
we're in the business of searching and
we're putting everything we can with the
data we have to search for the vessel
Mike Armstrong is in St John's
Newfoundland the base for much of the
search operation Mike what more do we
know about those noises detected
yeah well Donna there are two aircraft
flying 14-hour shifts they drop sonar
boys into the water and they listen well
yesterday both yesterday and today they
heard something
we don't know what they are to be frank
with you the U.S Coast Guard says
experts are still analyzing what was
heard they are describing the sounds
picked up by a Canadian P3 aircraft as
underwater noises now some have
described those sounds as possibly
banging that is what the crew on board
the sub would do if they were stuck
trying to be found but it could also be
something else animals or debris
clanging the Coast Guard will only say
remotely operated vehicles have been
deployed in the area where the sounds
were heard but have so far not found
anything we hope that when we're able to
get additional rovs which will be there
in the morning the intent will be to
continue to search in those areas where
the noises were detected and if they're
continuing to be detected and then put
additional rovs down in the last known
position where the search was originally
taking place
there are now five ships searching
around the site of the Titanic wreck the
Canadian Coast Guard Icebreaker the
Terry Fox headed out from the St John's
Harbor this morning five more ships are
on their way arriving in the next 24 to
48 hours but the area they're searching
is growing wind waves and currents mean
the sub could have drifted the search
area is now the size of Lake Erie and
about four kilometers deep we want them
to come home they want them to come home
safely the company that owns the ship
that launched the Titan spoke out for
the first time Wednesday the ship and
its crew are still on site participating
in the search this is an unprecedented
situation but I can assure you that
they're handling their responsibilities
very professionally and fully focused on
trying to find the submersible and bring
those people back safely you know it's
it's obviously very distressing Colin
Taylor knows the missing sub he went
down in the Titan last summer to the
Titanic wreck Taylor also knows two of
the missing men this is not a tourist
operation the CEO of the company that
runs the sub Stockton rush and French
Maritime expert Paul Ari narzole Taylor
says the sounds picked up underwater are
finally some potentially positive news
you know knowing pH Nursery is on there
ex-french Navy
uh I am sure he is there tapping away on
those titanium domes uh hoping that
someone is listening now two of the
missing Men Are from a wealthy Pakistani
family they are a father and son when
Taylor went down last summer he also
took his son along he says they went
through all the preparations and the
training but before they went down he
took his son aside and he asked if he
was really ready if he really wanted to
go through with it he was and it went
off without a hitch but with a father
and son now missing it's been hard for
Taylor not to think about that part of
it Sunday by the way launch day was also
Father's Day there is of course also the
horror to think about what those men
could potentially be going through right
now with their oxygen running out at
this point they would only have about 10
to 20 hours left Donna okay Mike
Armstrong and St John's thanks here is
some context the Titan submersible is
about the size of a minivan and Cruz as
Mike said are searching an area the size
of Lake Erie for it it is a needle in a
haystack and since the haystack is the
Atlantic Ocean sonar boys first used
during the second world war could play a
critical role Eric Sorensen explains
what they are
if the submersible is to be found it
will almost certainly come with critical
help from this sonar boys deployed from
Canadian Forces Aurora aircraft sonar is
decades-old technology but still the
standard for searching in deep dark
Waters and they picked up the banging
noises that have given hope to Searchers
in the North Atlantic
can be brought to the surface the Aurora
aircraft dropped the torpedoes-shaped
sonar boys into the water first they
detect sounds so if there was a banging
from the submersible search teams can
triangulate where it's coming from but
also the boys emit sonar pings which can
bounce off an object so analysts again
can determine where the return Echo is
coming from it's not certain the noises
are from the sub they're trying to put
all the pieces together the noises have
been described as banging noises there
have been multiple reports of noises and
every one of those noises is being
analyzed tracked look for patterns and
reported upon that means eliminating
other sources of noise such as ships
crossing the Atlantic while still trying
to find a tiny vessel it's super super
small and if you're in the Titanic
wreckages all the other other things
there so where's the sub and wears
everything else so that's that's super
challenging with potentially a few hours
of oxygen left the banging noises have
revived hope for the crew on the Titan
yeah it changes my that starts uh
incredibly so now I have this giant
burst of optimism but as a deep sea
veteran David Gallo's optimism is
tempered knowing what the men on board
are going through if they're still alive
everyone that's been to the sea to the
bottom of the sea in the submarine uh
has feared this and wondered what would
happen if this happened if you were
trapped there and with air slowly
running out would be just horrible I
don't like to think about it for the
next several hours what everyone is
thinking about and hoping for is finding
the Titan crew alive and well Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
French vessel racing towards the search
area is the only one carrying a remote
operated vehicle capable of going deep
enough to reach the Titanic site it's
extremely risky especially in a vehicle
like the missing Titan a former employee
was reportedly fired after raising
safety concerns about the submersibles
hull during deep Dives and the New York
Times obtained a 2018 letter from the
Marine technology Society calling the
construction experimental and saying it
could result in minor to catastrophic
outcomes a BC company leading the
industry in the design of subsea
autonomous vehicles shares those
concerns nithu Garcia reports
these are our control racks that we can
actually move those out to service them
Don Muth has been working in the
submarine engineering industry for more
than 40 years I started out as a
mechanical designer here he says he has
concerns about how the missing
submersible known as the Titan was built
there's obviously some concerns because
this is not a standard construction
submersible normally they'd be
constructed out of either a high
strength steel or a titanium according
to the Titan spec sheet on Ocean Gate's
website the pressure Hull is made of
carbon fiber and bonded with a titanium
ring carbon fiber has been known to
catastrophically fail the poor Coquitlam
BC company mute works at provided the
control system for the French sub sent
to help in the search effort and they
built a Canadian government sub also on
standby to help the Canadian government
one that we built for them is a 5000
meter depth one and Titanic has less
than 4 000 meters this is an example of
a more industrial grade one we run the
whole thing with this game controller
some of the testing for the Titan was
done in Everett Washington in 2018 the
same year a letter obtained by the New
York Times raised the alarm about
potential safety concerns which could
have consequences for everyone in the
industry we just imagined ourselves out
there
it's something that when we when we
built man Subs
we've always said if it's not safe
enough for our children to go on it's
not safe enough for us Ocean Gate says
important components like the pressure
vessel were solidly engineered alongside
NASA Boeing and the University of
Washington everybody's Gravely concerned
they really are it's a
tugs at your heart
mute says it's a small community in the
submersible industry with big hopes for
a positive outcome
Global News Port Coquitlam BC
a little later we'll hear from one of
the men who survived history's deepest
underwater rescue with just 12 minutes
of oxygen left in other news the Royal
Canadian Air Force says it will not be
grounding its Fleet of Chinook
helicopters after a fatal crash in
Ontario two crew members died when their
helicopter went down near Garrison
Petawawa during a night training
exercise two others have minor injuries
as Mackenzie gray reports a full
investigation is underway
they call them Waters near paduabo
Ontario returning to normal after a
desperate search ended in despair I can
confirm that the two missing Canadian
Armed Forces members were found deceased
by Searchers yesterday
the Canadian Armed Forces wouldn't say
if they knew why Chinook helicopter
crashed into the Ottawa River during a
trending exercise early Tuesday morning
nor were they released the names or
positions of the deceased by respect for
the family we're not going to discuss uh
we're not going to discuss the status of
the deceased whether they were pilots or
or air crew members but just hours after
that press conference the former Defense
Minister and current International
Development Minister arjit sajan tweeted
out it was two pilots who died I know
from personal experience having flown
that aircraft that the water egress from
the front of that aircraft where the
pilots sit is extremely problematic the
speculation of who died bringing back
painful memories for veteran Ralph
Kendrick you never lose the thought that
it could be you too and
that's happened a lot of time today
Kendrick is the president of the local
Legion a fixture in a town of less than
twenty thousand where nearly a third of
the residents work on the base it could
be one of the guys that sit down here
with us socializing on Friday afternoon
or beer call we don't know
they're all they're like I said they're
all family
despite the crash the Air Force hasn't
grounded the Chinooks if there's any
indication of technical issues that
would typically cause Applause until
there's enough information gathered to
make some informed decisions but in this
case I think they have enough
information to make a sound judgment on
you know continued flight operations the
next step for the military figure out
how and why the crash happened an
investigation the defense minister
wouldn't put a timeline on Donna all
right Mackenzie gray and pedawawa
Ontario thank you in Manitoba another
woman a passenger on that bus that
crashed near Carberry has died that
means the total number of debt is now
16. Health officials say nine others are
still in the hospital four of them in
critical condition last Thursday a
transport truck and a passenger bus
collided the bus was carrying 24 seniors
on a day trip to a casino a memorial is
planned for tomorrow and the victim's
names are also expected to be released
fiery crash on the 401 in Ontario last
night left two people dead Ontario
Provincial Police say a fuel tanker hit
the center median and rolled over
rupturing the tanks and sparking this
huge Fireball two other vehicles got
caught in the Flames officers are asking
anyone who saw the crash in Pickering or
has dash cam footage to contact them
NBC two people are dead after a plane
crashed on the west coast of Vancouver
Island it happened Tuesday afternoon the
plane with four people on board was
flying from maced on haidugai to Tofino
when it crashed at the head of the tacos
Inlet two passengers were rescued the
extent of their injuries is not known
and the cause is under investigation
a time to connect with family and with
their Heritage coming up the Traditions
being celebrated on National indigenous
people's day
oh
the House of Commons observed a moment
of silence today to Mark National
indigenous peoples day which coincides
with the summer solstice this year it's
a day of cultural significance for First
Nations Inuit and metis peoples and
ceremonies and events are being held
across the country Melissa ridgeen has
more on the history behind the day
we would start off the day with the pipe
ceremonies and sunrise ceremonies it
helps us to understand our roles to
to the Earth through through those
stories about the summer months and
grandfather's sun and it's really about
a time of coming together these
centuries-old ceremonies held by many
First Nations give appreciation to their
relationship with the land the summer
solstice is to honor the Sun and all of
the the crops and plants it and life and
brings like reciprocity and how we're
supposed to get offsprings to
um Mother Earth and the elements that
that provide for us and mark the start
of the busy season so our Summer
Festival kind of kicks off the pow-wow
season if you will so this is a time
where we will travel to different
communities and share different nations
will share their culture and the way
that they did things
while summer months are a time for
movement and socializing winter solstice
in December marks the beginning of the
slow season for introspection and
precious time at home when we talk about
winter it's about time of like
storytelling it's a time of learning and
being with your family newcomers now
share this land and both women see value
in Sharing culture I think it's
important to share our ceremonies and
teachings
um because it gives an understanding of
our relationship to the land our recent
identity is all based around trauma and
that's how people view us we are a
generation that is is actually moving
forward you know
um a lot of us are are turning back to
reconnecting with our ceremonies or our
ways of life and those with curiosity
and good intentions are always welcome
I'm honestly really excited to be able
to share part of my culture with
education comes you know knowledge and
knowledge of each other is really what's
going to be about fostering better
relationships Melissa Ridge in Global
News Winnipeg
ghost gun raids ahead a nationwide
investigation into 3D printed firearms
a massive emergency response in the
heart of Paris today after an explosion
left more than 20 people injured
including four who were in critical
condition the blast partially collapsed
a building that housed a private design
school a search is underway to determine
if anyone was inside at the time A Cause
hasn't been determined but Witnesses
reported a strong smell of gas before
the explosion
45 people have been arrested and more
than 400 Firearms seized in canada-wide
raids targeting makers of so-called
ghost guns weapons produced using 3D
printers this is a major operation it's
a first of its kind
the results are outstanding
the practice put in place of a
collaboration on this type of criminal
phenomenon also now gives us the
flexibility and the agility to do it
again with much more rigor and Agility
police say the investigation started
last November thanks to intelligence
from Canada Border Services there were
64 raids in eight provinces involving
more than 20 police forces 3D printed
guns printers silencers and ammunition
are just some of the items seized those
arrested range from 16 to 70 years old
homicide investigators held an update
today on the killing of a prominent
leader within the sick community in
Surrey BC he was shot on Sunday in the
parking lot of the godwara where he
served as president
I have no reason to say that the Sikh
Community is in any further danger at
this point this was a targeted incident
where one person was the target
Hardeep Singh nijar was found with
multiple gunshot wounds inside a vehicle
outside the guru nanak Sikh guruwara
police say The Killing appears to be
targeted najar's death has sent shock
waves through the community he served
police say they're looking for two
masked suspects who fled the scene on
foot and are asking for witnesses to
come forward
holding on to hope next how a man
survived 84 hours trapped in a
submersible
those five people on board that missing
submersible made a choice to get inside
at knowing how risky it was they went to
see the wreck of the Titanic but plenty
of other people actually work in
submarines every day 50 years ago Roger
mallinson and a colleague were laying
transatlantic phone cables from a
canadian-made sub when something went
wrong they were trapped for 84 hours
Redmond Shannon met the man whose story
is still the deepest successful
sub-rescue in history
we were working in severe conditions and
things just started going wrong Roger
mallinson recalls the longest 84 hours
of his life in 1973 he and Roger Chapman
were being lifted to the surface in
their sub after a shift laying cables on
the Atlantic seabed when something went
terribly wrong with the tow line we'd
taken four minutes to come up
when we went down it took us 26 seconds
and we hit bottom at 40 mile an hour
and we hit bottom at 1
575 feet down and we hit
like a major road crash it sparked a
huge International Rescue effort off the
coast of Ireland the two Rogers almost
certain that they were doomed keep on
praying and don't waste don't don't
exercise don't
use muscles because that's all
held Burns oxygen but Faithfully on that
mission malinson secretly brought an
extra oxygen tank giving Rescuers more
time to scramble with small submersibles
flown in from Canada and the US on day
four after numerous failed attempts
teens eventually attached cables to the
stricken Pisces three and we went from
being stern down to banging and crashing
and things were breaking and
and they were lifting Us by the back end
bruised and Queasy on the surface they
had just 12 minutes of oxygen left
before opening the hatch of their North
Vancouver made sub mallinson says its
sturdy design helped keep them alive no
compared to silly bits on it it was
honest and straight and it was very very
well made
Chapman has since passed away five
decades on from the rescue malinson's
thoughts are now with the five men who
descended in the Titan understanding the
depth of their plight perhaps like no
one else let's hope
let's hope they are safe Redmond Shannon
Global News troutbeck Bridge England
well National for this Wednesday I'm
Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada is
the harbor in St John's Newfoundland and
Labrador where the missing Titan
submersible departed from and now the
Hub of international efforts to find it
and the five people on board
thanks for watching bye-bye
thank you
[Music]